jojo liebe freunde und herzlich
willkommen zum ersten kontakt auf meinem
kanal und zwar fragt euch jetzt bestimmt
der revassist konto das hast du doch
irgendwann erwähnt und zwar habe ich das
in dem von 2.0 video erwähnt da habt ihr
habt ihr ganz wichtig geraten
und zwar habe ich da gesagt dass der
kontakt jede woche am mittwoch kommt
allerdings werde ich diese zeiten
bekommen einhalten können
da das doch ein wenig oft ich werde das
einfach unregelmäßig irgendwann mal so
hoch laden und naja ich denke ihr fragt
euch jetzt erstmal was dieser kontakt
sein soll und zwar besteht dieser konnte
aus zwei beziehungsweise drei elementen
zwei elemente die man dabei sind sind
einerseits meine meinung zu einem thema
da habe ich ja jetzt schon das video zu
julians blog hochgeladen allerdings wird
diese meine meinungs- serie sich in den
kontakt mit rein integrieren und dann
noch aus dem netz pusch ich weiß viele
leute senden wir immer noch täglich
mehrere nachrichten
ob sie denn nicht mal geputzt werden
können oder irgendwie tut guetta oder so
und auch bei konz blog auf meinem
zweiten kanal habe ich das ja letztes
regel macht die habe ich allerdings
wieder gelöschten wollte jetzt hier
weiterführen
das bringt natürlich viel mehr und das
sind die regeln ganz einfach schreibt
mir einen kanal in die kommentare
den ihr eventuell gepusht haben werden
wollt sein würden tun und dann werde ich
das eventuell tun dieser kanal sollte
ich werde gar keine grenze mehr setzen
sollte einfach weniger abonnenten haben
als nicht dass es ganz einfach weil wenn
er mehr abonnenten hat als ich dann ist
es irgendwie doof weil dann kennen denen
auch mehr leute als mich kennen dann
wird ein push nichts bringen naja ich
hoffe ihr seid damit einverstanden ich
hoffe ihr freut euch über diese
entscheidung und dann würde ich sagen
aus diesen zwei elementen besteht der
kontakt erst mal das dritte element ist
eigentlich noch immer so eine kleine
änderung auf meinem kanal kommende
projekte ebene kommentar frage oder
irgendwie sowas so etwas ganz
ausgefallenes sage ich mal
und ich würde sagen anfang erst mal mit
meiner meinung an viel spaß
ja und herzlich willkommen tsum meine
meinung und part von dem kontakt part 1
hier und zwar geht es hier um das iphone
ich bekomme täglich sehr viele
nachrichten was sich dann besser finden
oder auch in kommentaren ist es immer
wieder als thema ist mittlerweile schon
mainstream samsung gegen apple
3 ich glaube ja erst drei gegen iphone 5
oder irgendwie sowas
und ich möchte jetzt erstmal den ganzen
ein ende bereiten es sind beides nur
handys und jeder soll das nehmen was ihm
gefällt was er daran besser findet ihr
einen stehen mehr auf technik die
anderen stehen mehr auf einfachheit auf
einfachen es auf simple ist keine ahnung
wo ich eher das iphone nehmen würde na
ja ich würde erstmal zum samsung galaxy
s3 kann ich nicht viel beziehungsweise
gar nichts sagen ich weiß nur dass wohl
die daten ein wenig besser sind also der
kern die hardware als beim iphone aber
mehr auch nicht weil ich habe das handy
noch nie bei einfach meinen freunden
gesehen und ich habe das handy selber
auch noch nie so eine hand gehabt
deswegen werde mich noch nie darüber
informiert und ich wollte auch viel mehr
über das iphone 5 reden und zwar wird
das ja vor ein paar wochen vorgestellt
zwei wochen irgendwie so ich weiß sie
von dieser episode online kommt und ich
hasse euch mal ganz kurz alles zusammen
was es neue 1820 leichter zwölf prozent
weniger volumen also das design wurde
komplett verändert also nicht komplett
sondern ein bisschen immer noch
retina-display ultraschnelle daten kann
man damit nun runterladen
beziehungsweise um herschieben sag ich
mal soweit sie soll schneller sein
acht stunden kann man mit 3g surfen
blabla also neue a6 chip dann gibt es
neue kopfhörer die heißen ehepaar
ziffern jahrelang in der entwicklung
angeblich es gibt panorama fotos die man
machen kann dann muss man sich dann
einfach so komisch im kreis drehen und
ein panoramafoto es gibt einen leitenden
connector der ist kleiner robuster und
beidseitig verwendbar es gibt eine
eigene karten app von apple weil die
dann nicht nur auf google maps setzen
wollen die youtube app wurde entfernt
mal eben so zwischendurch siri kann
jetzt noch mehr sagen nur sechs neue
betriebssystem ist drauf es gibt also
dass man dinge überall teilen kann und
halt wieder ein
ihre apps das sind erstmal die ganzen
hauptsachen und ich finde man kann schon
sagen es ist das beste iphone aller
zeiten
das muss man sagen weil es ist ein es
kann sich nur verbessern das kann ich
wirklich schlechter werden aber ich
finde das so das nötige etwas fehlt was
bei apple sonst immer dabei war ich
meine beim iphone 4 war es jetzt zum
beispiel dabei dass man komplett neues
design und diese isight kamera mit
facetime iphone 4s war siri mit der
kommt man richtig reden das fand ich
auch genial iphone 5 es ist größer wow
ich meine dass man chip vergällt
verbessert dass man die batterielaufzeit
verbessert dass man vielleicht neue
kopfhörer dazu packt usw ist ganz schön
und gut aber das ist bei jedem neuen
handy bei jedem hersteller das immer neu
und ich meine jetzt ein bisschen das
design verändert aber ich finde es
fehlte das gewisse etwas was es bei
apple bisher immer gab
und seit die jobs nicht mehr da ist gibt
es das nicht mehr ich meine er hat ja
auch am iphone 4s mitgewirkt kamen
facetime
da kann sich dann dazu der vorhalt auch
immer mit ihm ist das unternehmen jahr
bergauf gegangen sieht man auch an der
börse an dem man den aktienkurs
es ist einfach unglaublich wie die zeit
ab gehen aber ich finde übrigens hat
apple heute wieder 17 punkte verloren
dass man nur am rande
aber ich finde dass beim iphone 5 dieses
gewisse etwas fehlt was apple bisher bei
jedem gerät irgendwie neu gemacht hat es
mag zwar dünner sein leichter es soll
übrigens auch noch den besten bildschirm
haben den es je gab besser als beim s 3
und beim iphone 4s
also den besten nennen die desktop
bildschirm den es den den sie je verbaut
haben und das mag zwar vom design ganz
gut sein ich hab auch schon selber im
handel ist das kann man nicht abstreiten
ist es extrem leicht und liegt locker an
den rand und alles weiter und das ist
auch wirklich viel viel schneller man
kann viel schneller fotos machen und
auch abspeichern
aber ich finde halt dass die das gewisse
extra fehlt was ja wie gesagt was immer
so dabei war was apple ausgemacht hat
von daher würde ich diesem gerät wenn
dies bewerten müsste auch wegen den
hohen preisen
ich glaube ich wird dem eine 2+ geben
warum keiner 1 wie gesagt ich finde
dieses gewisse etwas fehlt jetzt kommt
natürlich wieder leute an und meinen hey
dann sag uns doch was dir daran fehlt
kann ich nicht sagen das ist es ja ich
weiß einfach nicht was daran fehlt es
ist einfach nur ein iphone
man könnte es theoretisch iphone 4s spss
ist jetzt natürlich habe ich nicht
gesagt dass alles anders bezogen nennt
es einfach iphone 4 als 2.0 oder iphone
4s 2 oder irgendwie so will ich es eher
an den 5 ich finde man kann es nicht
einfach fünf erdteile haben es gibt auch
noch so eine tolle apps facebook da kann
man nun seine tickets fotografieren
irgendwie oder ein speichern und dann
kann man einfach sein iphone vorzeichen
anstatt einem stück papier bin ich
eigentlich unnötig aber naja die youtube
app wurde entfernt wegen gema und sobald
es gibt neue karten app und so weiter
aber ich finde das nicht so tolle sachen
die man jetzt wirklich beim iphone 5
also ich finde wenn wenn wenn wenn sie
schon sagen iphone 5 dann muss noch ein
bisschen mehr dazu und auch ein paar
sachen die die konkurrenz setzt noch
nicht hat weil das hat apple bisher
endlich immer so ausgemacht finde ich
also das ist wie immer meine meinung
eure meinung einfach unten in die
kommentare christoph stift nehmen auf
den bildschirm schreiben rennen habe ich
das schon zu lesen und dann für dich
sagen dass wir jetzt zum letzten putt
kommen dann kommen wir jetzt mal zum
würzburg so und damit herzlich
willkommen zum zweiten teil vom kontakt
nummer eins und zwar dem netzteil heute
wird geputzt der sturz ehepaar hat den
werden wahrscheinlich einige schon von
den amc kennen der ja mit ihm die formel
1 saison gelingt machen wir glaube ich
oder beziehungsweise weiß nicht ob die
saison spielen werden denn da gibt es
probleme mit cosmos da habe ich gehört
oder irgendwie so um den dreh da gibt es
ein paar problemchen jedenfalls kennen
den wahrscheinlich einige schon daher
ich kann dir den schon vorher als er
damals mal privat wird need for speed
irgendwie sowas gespielt hat aber auch
noch nicht so lange und ich habe mir
schon gedacht hin zu pushen und das
mache ich jetzt einfach mal es seit dem
24 12 2010 auf youtube ist keine ahnung
alt weiß ich auch gar nicht ich würde
ihn einfach mal so auf 17 schätzen 17 8
sensoren den dreh eine beschreibung ist
eine leidenschaft ein ziel dicht
soziopathische unterhalten
sei dabei wenn wir die piste von fast
jedem brandneuen rennspiel gemeinsam
rocken
und damit spricht das eigentlich schon
genau an und zwar seine projekte sind
zurzeit wenn ich das so richtig auf
zähle ein let's play von der showdown
jetzt dass let's play von formel 1 2012
dann außerdem hat er glaube ich noch
formel 1 2011 und need for speed the run
aber viel mehr weiss ja nicht er macht
nebenbei noch real live videos ich habe
ein video gesehen wo er einfach mal
gesagt hat ja ich bin jetzt hier am
prospekte austeilen und tschüss also
ganz witzige stumpfe sachen also ich
habe irgendwie noch nie schlecht gelaunt
erlebt haben ein paar videos angesehen
wirklich noch nie irgendwie schlecht
drauf oder so und eigentlich immer ganz
ganz ganz super drauf sieht alles locker
und dann ist das eigentlich auch ganz
gut also ich finde sondern so eine gute
laune let's player witzige sind gute
laune gamer dem solche leute braucht man
viel mehr auf youtube und ich kann euch
den kanal wirklich einfach nur empfehlen
vor allem dadurch dass jetzt auch was
mit den er macht es das wirklich so dass
du zusammen und da wird eben nur kranke
bei rumkommen aber diese kacke weht
anschober seien deswegen bezieht das auf
jeden fall rein kann alles in der
beschreibung aller abonnieren und dann
würde ich sagen war es das auch schon
vom kontakt nummer eins ich bedanke mich
fürs zuschauen zuhören ihr könnt auch
einfach zuhören beim nächsten
kontrollwoche dass das kein ganz gut
gesehen habe dachte ich das eigentlich
gar nicht angucken weil hier immer so
ein paar komische bilder sind ihr müsst
euch eigentlich einfach nur anhören und
dann passt das schon und dann würde ich
sagen sehen uns beim nächsten kontakt
ihr könnt mir wie immer einen kanal in
die kommentare schreiben und ein thema
mit dem ich mich auseinandersetzen
sondern meine meinung dazu sagen soll
tut mir leid dass ich hier oft ein
bisschen schnell gesprochen habe aber
ich hab's auch ein bisschen eilig und
bis zum nächsten mal bewertet das video
mit einem bauernhof in ist gut wenn ein
baum oder wenn ich schlecht dann ein
bisschen nicht mal tschüss